i'm not scarred
by what's happened like i believe
there's good men out there i believe i
will find one so how did you say like
i'm not gonna let this
ruin the next relationship i have what
the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed get in loser we're going
shopping with sophia and sistine we just
become best friends
can you say something
hi everybody and welcome back to another
episode of the unboxing podcast with
your favorite sisters where are you i
don't know what sound just came out of
my mouth but i'm not delusional yeah i
know yeah can i just tell you about my
24 hours sorry if i sound like i have
cotton swabs stuck up my nose just bear
with me
it's not covered just seasonal you know
i
have been
so tired and i know you've been tired
too but i'm the type of person i'm like
my mom
where we will go go go push our bodies
do the most and make time for friends at
the end of a very long day
just because we think we can no no we
can't so my body caught up to me
yesterday and said
you're done oh when i say shut down she
i like asked her i'm like basically in
some ways i go like tell me what's going
on now she's literally said how are you
and she's like dude and i
starts wailing starts yelling i was like
i just want to know how you are like
tell me what's going on i wouldn't talk
about it oh my gosh oh my god i needed
to cry for no reason
so bad
so bad
i'm not an occasional crier i'm not one
of those people where
if one thing upsets me i'm just going to
let it out because it's upsetting that's
so not true no it is true that's
absolutely false if something pisses you
off you start tearing up instantly
unless it's really bad but for mo
from the most part i would say i cried
less than the average person okay i do
you can say not i'm gonna care
let me have my moment lady yeah i have
your moment but you cry just as much as
scarlett does i do your point i'm just
saying
you yes are depleted and you're
exhausted and you're tired and you
definitely are the person to push
yourself the most and then when you hit
a wall you hit a wall and that's what
i'm scared
yeah but you you cry okay
no we i think both have completely hit a
wall like my skin has never looked worse
i am exhausted i've been waking up at
5am every single day but it's i think
it's the move the travel
the
it's other things too it's not just like
work-wise it's a relationships-wise it's
kind of getting everything set before we
do every i don't i don't think we've had
a break for one weekend yeah i don't
think i've been settled into one place
for
a few months honestly since for you new
year's
yeah yeah and i feel like my health has
been bad since new year
and uh not starting this year off great
but we're finally moved into our new
building thank god it is so beautiful
um we're living alone we're not living
together which has been a bit of a
adjustment yeah there's some pros and
cons to it i have to say what's your
cons
my con is the coffee isn't tasting as
good
but the price i make yes but the pro is
i'm not cleaning up coffee grinds all
over the table
the okay well
fair but it still tastes shitty so it's
okay because the coffee grinds are worth
the taste maybe i think so i think
that it's actually been more of a pro
than a con in general for me because
it's like i'm more responsible for
everything i do i miss you we live in
the same building we're fine it's like
we're that far from each other and we
face them each other and go to each
other's places except lately because the
scene's been his she's like i have been
loving
you it has been refreshing you i just
like having my space i like being able
to cook my food while you're saying it
smells bad cause i like to make eggs i
like to make them sorry eggs are stinky
someone starts to smell it doesn't like
cauliflower smells like there's very
specific smells that cestine doesn't
like that i wasn't able to make at our
old place so now i can do whatever i
want yeah um and i also think that it's
it's been good to kind of like be able
to decide on my own it probably for you
too like what you actually want in your
space because i've never really had that
freedom to go okay like what do what's
my interest because normally we have to
kind of agree upon it yeah and that's
like been really fun is buying all the
furniture and like seeing it putting it
together you've had like people in your
room every single day building [ __ ] oh
my god it's just
i haven't been alone i feel like there's
always just noise and chaos in my place
but now it's finally yesterday was the
first day that i actually sat on the
couch for 12 hours and did not move yeah
and um
it was
horrible i realized i like being around
people i hate being alone i thought i
loved it and i was like this is cool i
like it i was so lonely i'm so opposite
i realized how much i love to be alone
i i was thriving for four hours doing
nothing i was on the couch i was doing
like i was reading i was working i'm
like i can do this for another sex oh my
gosh i don't know why but you know we
had this problem the one bad thing i
love this place but one bad thing i had
happened to me yesterday that i'm like
nervous now about is the fact that the
elevators
are funky
i got stuck in the elevator yesterday
stuck and it wasn't just for like two
seconds it was for like a good 15
minutes and i don't know if you know
this
newly discovered i don't like
sightseeing i don't like tight spaces i
have claustrophobia now the thing the
the thing is with these newer buildings
is they're all electronic keys to get up
to get into your building to get into
your room
so in order for you to go to a certain
floor you have to scan your key it's a
whole thing so if you forget your key
you're screwed sophie gets locked in the
elevator i forgot my key in my room i
get locked out of my room and the
problem with this high-tech building is
i wasn't able to go to the lobby because
i didn't have my key and i wasn't able
to get back in this just because it was
on the floor so i was stuck in the
hallway for a close to 35 40 minutes
waiting for someone to hopefully walk i
don't know what's in this building
like we you actually have to wait for
someone to maybe like a contractor to
like walk in the room thank god and i
got lucky because i got stuck with a
contractor and he's like don't worry
it's okay like a walkie-talkie oh my god
thank god my boyfriend comes waltzing
around the corner 40 minutes later with
the bagel i'm like
hallelujah jesus
yeah but it's been good i'm i'm excited
to sort of just
make it more my own i still feel like
it's yeah no it's so i saw boxes and
things places i definitely need to hang
half the things i just think this month
is a little weird i'll be on like i
don't like fu march
i hate it's weird so i i told i actually
didn't tell you this but i went it was
when we were um
we were at target and then we you and i
separated after we got lunch and i went
to go get my friend a birthday present
and i went back to my car after getting
the present and i parked in front of
this girl and i could see her through
the
her car door window very clearly
and when i say she was
wailing i mean i have never seen someone
cry that hard are you sure it wasn't me
i'm not sure if i would like
i'm like
probably
probably
and then i sat in my car and i sat there
for like four more minutes kind of like
debating and when i say sobs i mean like
you could tell she couldn't breathe and
she was heaving and i was freaking out
she looked my age and i
get it and i was debating i'm like do i
knock on the window i'm saying
but that's the thing it's like no
because if she was doing it outside a
hundred percent would be like
you're good like do you need help and i
had this like urge to knock on the
window and be like dude what do you need
like do you need something so annoyed if
i was wailing in the car and someone was
like are you roll down the way are you
okay it's like you know do i look okay
so i want you stranger to approach me i
was waiting for the moment that maybe
she like would make eye contact with me
and i know like are you good but i mean
i've never seen someone sobbed at her
there is something so therapeutic about
a really hard sob
and i did it twice yesterday she she did
do it twice once to me once a month
i was kind of scared of the second one
didn't know
what i was crying about but it felt so i
felt so much better
i felt so good this is a psa
pause this podcast cry really hard and
then come back perfect that sounds great
this weekend i'm headed out of town but
so you have actually time to recover
i'm going to dc for the first time i've
never been very excited i'm so excited
i'm meeting up with mom and dad there
which is going to be really fun to see
them um but i don't i don't like really
know what to do there like do i just
look at monuments i mean i've never seen
the monuments so i guess i'll just walk
around and look at the white house and
this is what you do you break into the
white house mm-hmm yeah the fence okay
jump the fence go into the oval office
of course make unwaxed podcasts
its own news statement i bring the
sticker
i put it on the podium
no you give the president a hug you
stick it on his back he'll have no idea
he said gotcha yeah
he's like wait why is joe biden's having
on a box behind him no i'm excited
because i know that you said someone
described dc as a cleaner version of new
york
would you say that's accurate or would
you say it's more dc is sort of like
a cooler hamptons that is the bougiest
thing i've ever said i've never been to
hampton never been to hampton's either
but i can imagine for what it looks like
similar yeah well i'm extending the trip
just because i figured like i don't want
to just be there for one day i'm going
for an event on friday where i'll see
why else are you going to dc
to look at
statues of abraham lincoln other than
anything else
eating good food food alone
probably not probably not yeah you have
company i'll have company no i'm going
with someone i'm excited about so we'll
see how that goes well
before you go
i'm very excited for your trip we're
gonna have a lot of fun but before you
go i'm gonna make sure
i hand your company
um some manscaped before the big trip
that's right baby
this is manscape dad
take it away
as you guys know our friends at
manscaped the global leaders of the
below waist hygiene are turning men's
shower dreams into their new favorite
routine with the all-new ultra premium
collection
this all-in-one hygiene skin and hair
bundle is designed to upgrade the
everyday man-shower routine from head to
toe trust us ladies
his skin his hair and his balls deserve
this the men in our lives have become
much more confident since using
manscaped i have to say
let us help give your man a new hygienic
routine you'll appreciate you guys step
one have him lather on the cologne
infused ultra premium body wash if
you're not sure you heard that correctly
ladies but this body wash is cologne
infused so i promise you will also love
it i'm sure you love that sophia you
love a mancin i love the step two apply
the two-in-one shampoo and conditioner
that cleanses and nourishes all in one
step
he'll apply this to his armpits and his
pubic region too
step three once he's out of the shower
he'll be free from the body odor by
applying on the manscaped aluminum free
deodorant thank god and if he has
tattoos tattoos tattoos or dry skin
manscaped has him covered with a
hydrating body moisturizer spray
now this is the time to celebrate
because manscaped and we all hate
chopped lips threw in some manscaped up
lip balm and that's not only the best
part of it because we all hate chapped
lips so it's time to celebrate because
manscape even threw in some manscaped
lip balm this is a free gift when you
purchase the ultra premium collection we
love free and last but not least
you guys you know how i feel about this
next product he will want to use the
lawnmower 4.0 electric trimmer to clean
off any unwanted body hair the lawnmower
4.0 is waterproof so you bet it's a
major key to the new shower routine not
to sound like tony robbins but this new
bundle will change his life and it will
change yours all right
this is how you get in on it you guys
get 20 off plus free shipping with the
code unwaxed
that's 20 off plus free shipping with
the code unwaxed manskip.com let's get
the man in your life nice and clean with
the new manscaped shower routine oh and
it rhymed
[Music]
i know that this is kind of old news and
everyone's seen it and their mother and
their grandma and their dog but euphoria
i mean you were a huge fan of this show
but i kind of was slow burned into it i
was die hard season one fan season two
did you hear that season one fan season
two just
was a little bit
slow for me i didn't like it at all i'm
sorry i thought the only plot i liked
was between
maddie cassie and nate but everyone else
didn't really have a storyline but they
didn't really highlight that plot a lot
and they left so many
open ends to so many stories like cat
didn't have a storyline
i mean i think lexi was the only one
that i thought had a start to finish
start to finish and i thought hers was
really well developed um but even fez
and lexi's relationship was kind of
open-ended
uh yeah but i just i'm sorry i hated the
finale
it was so the play
the play part that i would have loved to
attend that play that was epic would you
have gone on stage
me yeah from the audience yeah
no why would i disrupt a play well
everyone started running on stage after
yeah they were trying to beat the [ __ ]
out of cassie
no way i'm not doing that like daddy hit
me no way i just i don't know i just
feel like
those shows when they get
they're
very creative and they're beautifully
designed and the makeup the aesthetics
the clothing everything is great but
i just think when they overdo it and
they completely miss out on the
character like for example this is
totally opposite show but there's a
reason why everyone loves the show and
it's pretty much set in one place
yellowstone totally opposite i know i
started that yesterday good the reason
why everyone loves the show is because
they love the character development you
really get to learn about every single
character's start to finish back story
why they act the way they do and you
kind of feel like there's some sort of
resolution at the end of it but this one
just like it kind of didn't have that
yeah for me i totally agree i was upset
that i didn't see more
of maddie
i thought she was going to hook up with
them yeah
i was pretty upset that didn't happen
also you know what i don't like about
high school shows
and so many
you know gossip girl one tree hill all
of them are the same
the characters in euphoria maddie is 31
30 i'm pretty sure and she's playing a
17 year old see that i'm like why don't
we just hire at least mid-20s okay you
know
let me actually counter this because i
agree with you because i'm looking at
like vampire diaries i'm like if this is
high school it's gonna be if the guys
are gonna look i'm gonna be disappointed
i would be stoked
well you know you go to your high school
and you see everyone as well i'm saying
when i saw it before high school i was
thinking if that's how high school it is
that i'm excited for it then you go to
high school and everyone looks like
they're [ __ ] has like acne yeah
people are still like maybe drinking
facial hair um
but you look at shows like the new high
school musical show and those kids are
they're they're probably in their early
20s 19 18.
i can't pair
high school musical
characters to euphoria characters they
are the corn balls of the century yeah
they look
it's teeny bopper i'm talking like when
they're trying gossip girl
you're telling me serena van what's
worth certain what's her name serena
i've never seen this
yeah is 16 i don't understand that girls
i try to get into it once i don't get it
it's pretty bad it's i feel like you
have to it's one of those shows you have
to watch at the moment you know what
show is realistic and holds up to its
time and will never go out of style
sex in the city that show
makes so much sense
sometimes if i'm going through something
not the new season
not and just like that we are not
talking about just like that that
shouldn't exist when we're talking about
show
first of all
i didn't like writing pelotons before
this proves my point big dying on a
peloton sorry if i ruined it for you but
like i saved you
that show is so good samantha jones
gives the best male advice one day i'm
just gonna type out a bunch of quotes
that she says bring them to a podcast
and you guys will understand it's it
like stands the touch no i i agree with
that i don't think i could watch it
consecutively for so long because
it's very monotone in the same beat
every single episode but i agree with
you it does still have actually really
really good advice
sometimes i think sometimes it's a
little toxic but you know we always yeah
i mean but
stay on brand i know i don't i just
started watching the new show also
marvelousness maisel i think that's such
a funny show if you've ever seen it it's
so good the new season's out but you
know i think cincinnati can agree that
our favorite shows are reality tv
i can't i'm sorry i love it it's it's
true and you know why it's our favorite
is because
if you really get a great cast it's real
and the [ __ ] that goes down behind the
scenes is not fake and we've met some
people from behind the scenes of
whether it was like real housewives of
beverly hills or maybe it's below deck
or whatever it is they are who they are
on camera but i have to say i mean i
wouldn't say every reality show is real
there's definitely like kardashians is
definitely loosely scripted
but
my personal favorite reality show i know
for fact is real emotions real character
dynamics real relationships it's called
vanderpump rules and when we say that
it's her favorite show and i've sat with
her we've watched probably the
seasons all the way through three times
season one the season eight three times
we just finished season eight
okay i'm halfway through season one
right now
we restarted starting a backup
and i can't wait to hit season four do
you want to know why i can't wait to hit
season four why can't you wait because
my favorite character she really is
steps onto the scene of vanderpump rules
in season four and guess what we have in
store for you guys today
the
la la kent from vanderpump rules is
coming on today frickin
sitting on this couch in the next 15
minutes we know her but i'm still really
really excited and nervous i feel like
i'm i don't know you know why i love
watching her so much she is so badass
yeah she came onto this show
so unapologetically herself basically
saying this is who i am if you like me
cool let's be friends if we don't that's
not my problem i love her confidence her
boldness i mean she is her skin is
beautiful her skin's beautiful she's a
boss woman she's a mom i mean we have so
much to unpack with her today
all right guys
this strong badass woman made her
presence known when she stepped onto the
la scene becoming a fan favorite on the
hit reality show vanderpump rules she is
now owner and creator of her own beauty
brand called give them lala podcast host
published author actress and now new
mommy
we have the beautiful lala kent on
studios
we are freaking out i don't know if you
realize because actually we are huge
fans of yours like before we even met
you like we were sistine's watched
probably vanderbilt yeah let's talk
about that no honestly we
have always admired you we thought you
were so beautiful we loved your energy
on the show and then meeting you in
person first of all we have to tell that
story of how we've been met in person
but you were all of those things and
sometimes you see people on tv and
you're like oh they're one way but you
were that and more yeah and you i
remember you came over to our house for
you joined our family dinner one night
and we were so chaotic and i was so
shocked we didn't scare you i felt right
at home actually oh my god i know that's
what i did i know because we were like
oh my gosh she can hang with us like she
can actually keep up with our
obnoxiously loud like conversations at
dinner no you have the cutest family
like leaving your house i was like that
is like a sweet close family because
nothing was off limits yeah the way you
guys talk in front of your parents is
kind of how i would talk in front of
mine you know you'd think if you had
guests over that your your family unit
would act a little bit more polite and
yeah well-mannered and we were exactly
the opposite of that so we were so
shocked that you know i was like
cool with it that was like the fir you
guys were
i think the first
people that i had like
been around
had i even announced that i was no no i
told us you told us that day that you
were pregnant and i think you just found
out and you're like no one else knows
yeah yes you're right god and we're like
no we're the first or not like it was a
badge of honor no no i mean how cool is
that though yeah yeah and my mom lost
her mind and my mom's like wait she's
pregnant my mom was like pregnant you
had mommy glow yeah i did you were such
a pretty pregnant lady thank you did you
like being pregnant i loved it the first
like three months i was
very sick like morning sickness like
yeah just like nauseous all the time
but then once i got through that i
loved it and after i gave birth that was
like my most favorite body too
really i just felt like all woman i was
like i just pushed a person out of my
cookie
i'm like
like you can't [ __ ] with me no you know
and i was feeling thick my boobies were
all huge and i was like feeding my young
with them i was like
wait but i love hearing that side of it
because i think a lot of women get
scared to get pregnant because they're
afraid of what their body will look like
after and the fact that you're like no i
felt more woman
now i want to get pregnant
no i loved it and and granted like from
afar because i
i definitely get it like you look at
certain people
and not everybody's body looks the same
after they give birth right right
and so for me being like well i loved my
body i can understand someone being like
please shut the [ __ ] up right right like
i'm well aware that my bounce back was
amazing but i kind of take it into a
different zone of like my body created
someone's brain right
how could you not look at yourself and
be i know that you grew as a human being
inside your stomach my child's going to
go off one day and like get a job
because she has a mind yeah you created
my money
you know
you have to pro you probably think of so
many interesting things like that that
you would have never thought about
before never
what's something that right when you
pushed her out did your mentality
completely change did you look at things
differently like did you prioritize
things differently
yes i think the second i the second i
got pregnant i could feel myself
becoming more motherly and just
interested calmer
i i'm still like a hot head but
you know like i take a beat now before i
react and then the second she was born
you look at the world and everything
that maybe you've done in your past
and you want to protect that baby like
you realize all of the beauty in the
world still because you see this like
innocent life
but you also realize all like the ugly
[ __ ] out there yeah that you'll do
anything to protect your kids right was
there anything about your pregnancy
because the one thing i'm scared about
and i always think about like there's
things that people say oh i didn't
expect this to happen to my body and
like maybe their nipples got bigger or
they just got more stretch marks or
whatever it was was there anything
during your pregnancy we're like i did
not expect that to happen or like change
okay so the first thing was
i didn't get hair anywhere what like my
legs like
my cookie i never had to shave it which
was good because i couldn't see it after
something like the most convenient thing
ever how weird is that
are you kidding me yeah laser hair
removal without actually doing wait but
i would expect it to be the opposite
opposite like i would be like
mom said her hair grew like a ton when
she was pregnant right like i was
waiting for that to happen i was like
where's this great hair everyone's been
telling me about because it ain't
hitting me right nowhere no like my
cookie was all clean i like rarely had
to shave my legs my nipples got
and dark like i have a heart tattoo
around my right nipple yeah and it was
now like my nipple was around my heart
i was like
i didn't think this tattoo through like
you have to like expand the heart now i
did think that my mom's like they'll go
down and i was concerned because i'm
like i'm gonna be breastfeeding with
like a heart tattoo like how trashy
oh
i mean like that's kind of cool that
she's looking at it's like she's looking
at your heart yeah
you're right it's like a special side
it's like your favorite yeah she likes
that
side no she likes the left i was like
the left gets all the love it's bigger
you know and there's always one that
gets more love there's always one that
gets more like did you try your breast
milk yeah it was good i used it in my
coffee a couple of times when we were
adding wait are there health benefits to
that though or yeah because there is you
can yes it's like i don't know what's in
it i think it's like full of protein
i don't know but you people sell their
breast milk on like the black market to
bodybuilders
yes we got to confirm this did you eat
your personality
i encapsulated it okay
i heard that's like amazing the vitamins
in there does that change anything like
does it do anything you know what i
think when i
would not take them like i'd missed days
i noticed my hormones were out of whack
and i'd kind of feel down oh
and when i would take them it would
balance me out because if you think
about it like your body creates this
organ and then it's like just gets rid
of it you know it's gonna kind of [ __ ]
you up a little more yeah for sure it's
like completely changes the natural
balance of your body and yeah just like
disappears i didn't feel right about
getting rid of it i'm like it did so
much work well i always forget though
with childbirth there's i think a lot of
people just assume okay the baby comes
out and ta-da you're done like no you
also gotta push out a placenta wait did
you have an epidural like that's crazy
does that hurt comfort that's
no can i tell you i passed out though
twice
when they when they put the like the
most easy thing
too and you can't get an iv
no what i literally they thought i was
seizing the only reason they they knew i
wasn't was because the baby's heartbeat
was fine okay so i was just passing out
it was just like right now is that bad
to like pass out when a baby in your
stomach i mean i don't think that they
want that to happen yeah i think they
would do like
yeah luckily she was fine the epidural
yeah i didn't even feel it because the
contractions were hurting yeah it feels
like the most intense
oh my god but you also have to remember
i got induced so i didn't feel much okay
okay
or did you do natural like a i did
cookie okay
but
like stassi yeah stassi like went into
labor on her own oh the water broke why
did you get induced
ocean was born three weeks early because
my
my placenta was old
like how's that pop yeah did you know it
thought well i went into my 20 week
appointment and they were super
concerned about ocean they said she's
like not growing
so what yeah so i had to go in every two
weeks since my 20 week appointment and
40 weeks is full term and they said her
head was growing but the rest of her
body wasn't and
as a mom you're freaking the [ __ ] out
yeah i mean like
you can't do anything no i was praying a
lot and drinking a lot of protein shakes
like doing anything right i could
because my placenta was thinking that my
pregnancy was further ahead than it
really was oh okay yeah that means i've
never even knew that it could do that
neither did that so interesting isn't it
weird that's really weird i don't even
uh so you were induced to the good thing
you didn't feel a lot of contractions no
i walked in they were like let's start
the process that's what the the iv in
the arm was to give you the pitocin or
whatever kickstart labor yeah and
what's her birthday march 15th oh that's
wait it's coming up yeah
next week on tuesday where's she at
tuesday aries
no she's a pisces oh how crazy i connect
with pisces that's actually perfect i
was gonna say is that why you induced
her at that time
some people do that how about sly did
that with scarlet little sister
she was on um the verge of becoming what
was the sign before gemini gemini
actually i think is it a tourist does
scarlett's um when's her birthday may
25th
he just said something like she can't be
a taurus so my mom oh oh yeah no april
is taurus yeah so she's like he's like i
can't have a taurus baby and so he made
my mom get into she'd be a gemini
so she's born in may yeah she's may 25th
it was something like what's right
whatever's right before well if it's
april
april end of april end of april i [ __ ]
yeah something like that but he made my
mom he was like no no i need to have a
job i can't have because end end of
march into april of something i'd have
to look would be taurus because our
cousin is the tourist she's april 10th
i don't think i
we're the same we're virgos virgo what's
yours i'm a cancer okay see familiar
familiarity i only know virgos and
cancers is
okay let's talk about
you before l.a you're from utah yes and
i show you guys something that i just
got yeah i got
my area code tattoo wait that's badass
wait when did you get that uh like last
week oh my god like you know what i need
to represent yeah
do you do you impulsively get your
tattoos or do you like to think them out
no i impulsively get them i also got mom
oh
that's cute so trashy no actually the
arm is like really cute no i like that
it's like if you've got a huge heart
around it i'd be like all right like
maybe you're literally
whatever sofia okay well so did you
decide that it had to be here dude you
were like thinking at any other place or
were you like i knew that i wanted a
tattoo there i definitely didn't think
it was gonna be eight oh one yeah
and you guys after i got it i was having
a panic attack i was like what have i
just done i was like i should have
gotten it over here because all my
tattoos are over here that's the comfort
zone no but now i love it it's balanced
no it's not bad it's balanced yeah i
like it you can't have everything on the
left so you don't want to just do like a
whole sleeve on one side it's good to
like disperse it right a little pete
davidson you know there's a little
little everywhere i put him everywhere
remember you're from the 801 you're from
utah yes when did you move to l.a did
you move to become an actress yes i
moved right out of high school
originally and i made it four months and
i was like i cannot do this this city is
not what i i thought it was going to be
like an episode of the hills you know oh
right right
i know everyone thinks that and then
they come here and we're like it's a lot
harder and horrible it's a lot harder
than i thought really hard yeah um and
then i moved back to utah i went to
community college for like two years
because i was just gonna be a normie and
i was like i [ __ ] hate this i'm going
back so i moved back at 23.
wow and
there was no other option and yeah i
wanted to be an actress i had been
acting and in the arts since i was 12.
but like it was it was just different
now no one cared about like where you
trained it was more about how many
followers you have on social media
was this like that back then too yes
it was like just starting and i was like
anti-social media like you don't need to
know what i'm doing right right i mean
why yeah why like why do you need to
know where i am no i always i still
think that i still think that too stupid
i agree no i still like i want to get to
that point where i actually don't need
to use my instagram at all anymore that
would be the life no but that's just a
girl
you know but the day that i can yeah
handing it over to someone else and i
want no part of it exactly i know i'm
like i don't feel like posting tagging
it's like also you guys are good at it
though oh you guys are [ __ ] at it
no you know what though we're so
inconsistent we won't post for three
weeks to a month and then we'll do one
post and we're like okay this is good
for another four weeks yeah like we're
never consistent no we don't have any
like our we have our management team so
like so what do you like focus on where
i don't know they're like what's your
pot your instagram around i don't know
we don't have like one consistent yeah
that people go to us for if i look at
your instagram you're so i know exactly
what i'm getting it's beauty it's baby
it's lifestyle it's home
awesome
clicks click and buy
but that's good oh my god bill's
japanese got a lot of swipe up chickens
goddamn toothbrush
were you always just like going back to
utah have you always been a very
outspoken confident person or at least
like maybe you weren't confident about
like just like a very like
school yeah i was
in high school well because
of the way that i was bullied in
elementary school
i became outspoken because that was like
my defense mechanism it was you know
like i just developed a very sharp
tongue
with everybody yeah
well it was like a moment that like made
you change like that or was just in
general over time like bullying and
things are like i need to just stand up
for myself i think it was me becoming
friends with like this group of girls in
about the fourth grade
that they were very clicky
and i was sensitive like i just that was
the type of person that i was and
i just figured i'm gonna start being an
[ __ ] you know because i mean because
it's easier if you're gonna be a [ __ ]
then i'm gonna be a bigger one right and
actually when you're i've always heard
this if you're some i mean if someone's
bullying you and if you kind of like out
speak them or out do them they always
like yeah they respect you in a weird
way yeah it also trains you to be like
angrier sometimes like oh yeah i feel
like i because i was bullied i like
later down the line started seeing
myself kind of turn into a bully
and i had to do a lot of self-reflecting
and figure out like why do you always
feel the need you know like you can
choose your battles yeah just because
someone disagrees with you doesn't mean
they're stupid
but i understand why you did that and
stood up for yourself because i mean we
can name a hundred moments where someone
was rude to us and then we don't say
anything and then a few minutes later we
go i wish i had said this yeah i wish i
had stood up for myself but then it is a
double-edged sword and you sort of
develop habits over time that you're
like okay these are kind of nasty i need
to get rid of them when you moved to la
at 23 did you still sort of have that
you know
shield of armor where you're like i have
to be tough and stand up for myself all
the time just because you're in a new
place new environment new people and the
industry is cut through yeah and being
in the acting world is [ __ ] tough
yeah when i came out here i was timid
yeah and
i just kind of wanted to fit in and you
know the girls that i was hanging out
with
they had been friends of mine since i
lived back home in utah so i knew them
really well but i was different like i
wore the big hoops and i was wearing
like my hats with you know whatever i
was just like yeah it was just different
from them right and they tried to tell
me like no this is
this is what's in style this is what you
should wear and i still wasn't fitting
in and i would go places and like people
wouldn't pay attention to me and i would
kind of just like fall into the
background yeah and i was like i'm not
doing this anymore like if i want to put
a green wig on with my nwa hat and the
biggest hoops you've ever seen then like
i want that's what i want to wear
and
people were kind of drawn to that and i
finally felt like myself i feel like
this city started giving me a lot of
confidence that i had never had right
but that's so interesting because i
think you're giving the city credit but
i want to give yourself credit because
i've lived in la my whole life and i
don't feel like it's given me any
confidence if anything it does the
opposite
so do you think that
because when you were on vanderpump
rules you were that person you had the
hoops you had the attitude you had the
best outfits
and a lot of the girls i feel like in
the beginning just did not like you and
like we're just because it's easier that
way just to sort of be against the one
person that wants to be themself
how did you not you know buckle down
because sometimes it's just easier to be
like okay i'm gonna swim with the stream
then go up it because i'd rather have
fun friends than be alone like how did
you continue to like
push through and be yourself
i feel like that just came with me
understanding the assignment
and i just like
i knew that if i didn't
exude a certain level of confidence that
they would eat me alive right and i knew
i can't go back to utah like this is it
this is i i'm here
i'm hoping that this will parlay into
something much bigger for me this is my
springboard so i really had to fake it
until i made it if if something i did
bothered them
i would do it even more like i can show
you how annoying i can get for you
you're upset that like i have a profile
picture of my ass i'm gonna take my top
off in front of your man oh you know
like
i wouldn't do those things now but
you're like you were so fun to watch
like you were so fun to watch i look
back and i'm like what were we doing but
at the same time i'm like without those
little moments i wouldn't have all of
the things that i have now and
i would have never grown and learned and
changed yeah
evolved
and you know i
have so many people that will try to
like take me back well you did this it's
like well let's talk about what i did
when i was 19 16. i mean we can always
evolve as people oh yeah we're allowed
to change who we are in like two years a
year right like so we don't have to be
the same person so it's so much easier
for someone
not in front of a video camera to like
pass judgment at you but when you have
reality tv shows constantly filming your
whole life
everyone is bound to make a mistake
especially if you're catching it on
camera it does make everyone look great
all the time is there something that you
did on the show that you're like you
know what if i could take it back i
probably would there's only one thing
i've ever done on vanderpump rules that
i'm like damn it really yes and that was
when i body shamed katie it was so
against
everything that i represent everything
that my mom had taught me like it went
against how i was raised like we don't
talk about
how people look right right you know
right yeah
when i did that that was a low moment
and i've done a lot of you know
the only thing that i look back and go i
wish i never would have done that no
because it's also like knowing you
that's totally not who you are at all
like you're so much like literally in
the beginning of the podcast your time
at how like you love your womanly body
you love like what it does like how it's
produced a child it's like it changes
and you love those changes i mean i feel
like
do you ever feel like your daughter's
gonna watch the show and go like oh my
like are you gonna show your daughter
the show and like sit with her and stuff
or you know everyone
asks me like a lot of people ask me
aren't are you going to be embarrassed
like what you wrote in your book and
it's like i want my kid to read these
things i want her to see that her mom
has had to face a lot of
different decisions
different circumstances this is how i
handled them i'm not perfect i want her
to know like
i've done my fair share of messed up
things i feel i've come out on top you
can trust me you're always safe yeah
i'll never judge you i love that because
i feel like even when our mom opens up
about things like she's done in the past
she's not done like that much but
whenever she does open up more it
actually we relate to her more exactly
and we actually yeah we get closer and
we almost like don't do the same
mistakes or we at least if we do make a
mistake we feel comfortable enough like
you're super close with your mom to talk
about it okay you know because she's
probably open with you about things that
she has i think that's so important i
like that you're going to show your dog
i wish like i want to be there with you
guys too because honestly it it shows me
that you are already going to have such
a close relationship with her the fact
that you're willing to be open and say
like you know when i was this age i made
mistakes but you're gonna learn from
them that is the reason why sofia and i
have so
such a tight-knit relationship with
scarlett as well like being open
is the best thing for a mother-daughter
relationship i agree with you were you
like that with your mom oh my god i i
would walk in the front door and be like
i gave my first blow job oh my gosh
like i don't want to hear that and i'm
like you gotta leave my gun because it
was
because then you don't feel shameful for
doing things like it's like
it's normal like when you have your
first [ __ ] or like to have sex for
the first time like i'm well aware that
my daughter is going to pick up a drink
at some point in her life exactly she's
going to have sex she's going to make
mistakes
and tricks i mean if she asks
if she asks me but i also want her to
know like
there's always a time and a place for
things and
i know
because of my experiences
if you choose to go and drink i hope
that you don't drink under 21 but if you
do because i get it i've been to high
school before
please call me if you need a ride like
all of these little things of just like
i never want her to
feel like she can't call me you're going
to be the coolest mom ever i hope i'm
with the trusting mom his mom first of
all you're already dressing like a cool
mom you're already a milf which is so
exciting oh my god that's like our one
goal in life
but like it's part of the few goals i
have what age what age um
for ocean are you like really excited to
get with her because it could be you
know 16 or maybe
25. can you imagine her as a 25 year old
like no not at all i hope we're like me
and my mom when i feel like they're bad
for so many good like flirting to i feel
like you have really good flirting tips
do i i feel like i'm sorry
there's no like you're so confident
maybe it's just like you're gonna say
i'm just confident and like you'll be
the one to like go up to someone first
like have you always been like are you
i feel like i'm good at it though
because like you just come off as just i
am who i am like if you're not into it
like don't want me and then the guys are
probably like what the [ __ ] like wait i
want you i mean
i slid into
someone's dm on christmas
and can i tell you how'd it go
i haven't slid into a dm since i was
probably 23 and hammered yes
so i slide into his dm with emojis okay
what emojis
please don't put flames no it's just i
did a flame
no
just listen
and like the like the show
actually i love that combination right
it sends me to emoji's bag and i was
like i'm going to be really honest with
you right now
i'm new to sliding into the gm so i'm
not quite sure what to do
but i just want to let you know like you
look good yeah what did you respond to
your flames he said
i'm so happy i saw your message and then
sent me his phone number
well
and then chef's kisses so guys if you're
ever trying to slide it into season
flames and chef kiss emoji you're in i
have no game but i warned him i was like
i'm like i don't have games well it's
better if you haven't been in the game
for a while that you're like oh [ __ ]
like how do i get back in the game yes i
know it's kind of scary no but it was
very scary that's great what's scary is
people don't really have a meat cute
today it's not like you're at a coffee
shop and you're like oh i'll pay for
your coffee what's your name let me get
your number now it's all about
dating apps sliding in the dm totally
god are you interested
yeah no i'm not in the zone of dating
apps i wouldn't you don't need to yeah
yeah dating apps are weird well
instagram's enough of a dating app as it
is like you can literally dm whoever
totally i agree
and i was talking to these two girls the
other day who are like super into sex
and stuff
um and they said they actually like
instagram better than dating apps
because you can look
at the profile videos to hear the voice
see who they follow their mutual friends
that is no i think it's so much i think
the only hard part is seeing if they
will see it
but like other than that i mean
like at least you have a surefire chance
of like it's 50 if they see it and they
like want it yeah or not there was and
because of like the zone i'm in right
now
honestly like if he never would have
seen it i wouldn't have cared and like
if he never would have responded i
wouldn't have liked so much other [ __ ]
tricks that's the trick to not care if
they don't answer or respond not at all
but a lot of people care yeah they get
really upset about it and then beat
themselves up about it so that's that's
have you been on a date recently like
because dating itself having a first
date recently because
first date after like not dating for a
while is so like you forget like i
literally remember the last time when i
got out of a long relationship i'm like
i don't know
what to talk about like what do you do
how do you how do you and i'm a virgo
like i ask you questions about your
family your job
i evaluate you like are you gonna be
expecting a checklist
exactly i'm like at the shoes the outfit
the hair like totally the tone is he
like funny is he not funny is the
texture of the voice high yeah exactly
are the hands small is it veiny is it
strong
[Music]
like that's the biggest like i know that
was like what i was overwhelmed about
like have you been on the first date
since i've
only been on
two dates with the same person in a
group setting
you guys are gonna think i'm so weird so
i have retained a pi because i'm so
scarred
that
anybody who i let in as like that i'm
interested in i run the background check
that is
awesome yeah
that's my job for her she's
yeah the same thing just she's free i
think that's kind of smart because like
did you have access to like um credit
checks and things like that no no
i'm doing it all
right
i'm seeing lawsuits you got felonies you
got
genius and there should be an app for
this because you're going to be saving a
lot of time if there are some criminal
records yeah or some unpaid things yes
that's so small i don't mess around so
the background check came back and i was
like it ain't gonna work out do you have
like a type that you're going for or are
you kind of like whoever's super what
you're a good person tall dark and
handsome with a lot of tattoos a lot of
tattoos yes we were saying that we loved
birds oh my god i couldn't
really see you with like someone fully
tatted yeah that's badass hot
yeah yeah wait how tall are we talking i
mean
depending on the build yeah you know
because you can't be like tall and lurpy
but like this last dude was like like
slenderman we don't want something
but he was like almost six eight but
like yolked six eight yes
the whole thing came back not right i
was like i can't say what
and then the pi came back going you know
yeah
i'm sure the pi thinks that i'm a nut
case but like no yeah fair no and it
takes a few a couple weeks two or three
weeks because i go in depth i'm doing
criminal i'm doing
money because then those two to three
weeks are crucial you could be getting
so close with him and then all of a
sudden no no no no no
our virgo brain you know we don't know
no we don't get it business or exactly
i'm like is this a good investment have
you had my time
are they going to make me gross have you
been on an absolutely terrible date
because saviy and i talk about it all
the time on the show we are always
talking about horrible because they want
more bad dates than good days we like to
i believe
no i've only actually been on those two
group dates
in life yeah like have you ever been on
a horrible date
yeah
like with a guy who asked me how i
wanted to split the check
oh we've had that oh i was like oh i
know the guy pushed the check to me
oh yeah i'll do you one better i was
like this one's on fly tonight i was
talking about the call
i was talking about how confident i was
i'm like yeah i feel really good about
this but he goes well since you're such
like a confident independent woman
with this i had a guy
not even halfway through the first
cocktail and he invited me to dinner
check slid his resume towards me
[Laughter]
no
and i thought he was so cute i was so
excited
i was like oh wow and we did this whole
resume was he an actor yeah well the
best part was this guy we have to tell
this story one day about how like we
kind of when cecina go out she's
interested in a guy like i help her get
break apart the friend and so she's like
i'm in a relationship now
with these stupid i know she's lucky i'm
struggling okay the shortest i would go
is probably six three
fair you're not therapists
my ex my ex is six seven so i got it
shooting for the [ __ ]
don't listen to yourself honestly yeah
okay you wanna know what's amazing sorry
that's fine see they're out there yeah
they are out there i'm so comfortable by
myself
that if he never arrives i'm good
exactly but that's a level of stability
that like a lot of people don't have and
something i still don't know yeah i get
you know how do you get that no i said
this and i was single for three years
and now i'm like i really want to cuddle
and i never like cuddling i don't like
being with anybody like i like being
alone but now i'm just like i need to i
miss companionship right but i feel like
there is a certain point where like oh i
kind of miss having a person next to me
to talk to you yeah what do you mean
about having like
a partner like next to you
or just being a such a hard question
um
i haven't been in like a healthy fun
relationship since i was
with my high school sweetheart oh my god
oh my gosh yeah you deserve one like you
think yeah what what's something that
like you are definitely not gonna settle
on for the next relationship that you
didn't get in your last one
um i want his time
phone use is a big one yeah right
um
i think those would be
contrary to what people think i'm not a
materialistic person like i don't need i
don't need gifts like even for ocean's
birthday people are like what does she
want for her birthday and i'm like
i didn't even think about the present
aspect i was like i was just excited for
you guys to come to this party party
like the house is there like i don't
know i'm not a gift person yeah i just
want like quality time and attention and
for us to have like a lot of like i have
to laugh with you have fun no totally
yes but i honestly get the whole pi
thing and like also wanting quality time
and stuff it's like
when you haven't when you can't trust
someone it's like it really just
completely deters you from like your
friend like you have to honestly you
almost over evaluate everything now and
it's so annoying because it like almost
ruins not ruins like the next
relationship but you you have to be so
much more conscious and aware and it's
just right it's so unfair i feel so bad
for when people have to like go through
that because then it just adds on a
whole other layer of
a part of like a relationship that you
need to consider which is like just the
loyalty yeah you know definitely that
that aspect though like yes definitely i
feel like the pi part is just like me
being
smart
you know but i feel like you're just
guarding your heart
you're just beyond that though
because that stuff is like the logistics
that's the business end because had i
gotten married
i would be dealing with a lot yeah so i
gotta make sure that who i'm dating
you don't have [ __ ] that's going to
affect me should we ever get married one
day like i don't even want to like
venture into territory with you like
that right the part about my heart
i you would think that i would have a
lot of trust issues
i don't really i'm not
i'm not scarred
by what's happened like i believe
there's good men out there i believe i
will find one that's really good i'm not
opposed to opening up to somebody oh i
love that you know but
a lot of people struggle with that so
why how did you get to that because like
you're i mean your situation is so much
i mean not that anyone's like cheating
things less severe but like you have a
child with him and all this stuff so how
did you actually come to terms and say
like i'm not gonna let this
ruin the next relationship i have
i this is like mean of me to say
but i'm honest
i don't feel like my heart was in that
relationship i felt like he was my best
friend right
like he was my best friend
that part i think was the hardest part
that i was like that
was like oh my gosh my best friend is
gone but like i don't
i wasn't in love you know when you know
you know when you're in love with
somebody totally i
wasn't there i don't i don't even know
if i was ever there i mean three years
of the relationship i was
hammered
and so it's it's
my relationship or my last relationship
is just
it's very messy and hard for people to
understand because
of the way that i defended him all the
time and what i portrayed and there will
be a day where i can talk about what it
was like behind the scenes for me in
that relationship right because i'm a
ride-or-die for my person i will never
not defend the person i'm with and then
if there's an issue i'll discuss it
behind closed doors
um
so
in that i think that i'm not affected
going forward into other relationships
because my heart really wasn't in it
right
what are you gonna teach ocean from like
this experience that you've had because
i know that she's probably gonna ask
questions like what are you gonna tell
her about with her future relationships
that you want her to remember like when
she's choosing a guy or a girl or
whatever she's you know yeah
um
that's gonna be a hard one to navigate
because
she's obviously going to read things
she's obviously going to have questions
but i believe that
children are very smart yeah i'm not
going to have to go into detail about
things with ocean right and my job is
is
to protect her at all costs and
there are certain things that i
know that like she doesn't need to know
you know
she just doesn't
oh if you're gonna make me cry in terms
of just protecting her i don't want her
to
find someone
like
that person but she will because she
sees you doing that yeah and she saw
that you are making a better choice for
yourself which will she'll copy because
kids are like sponges they'll do the
exact same thing it's just teaching her
her self-worth and like you were strong
enough to go you know what i don't
deserve this i don't need this and your
daughter's gonna watch that alone and go
you know what
because my mom was strong enough to go
and change her whole life and switch
around and within like a week
that i can do the same thing yeah
i hope that that's how it goes like my
biggest fear is when she starts getting
older and has questions and you know
like
i don't know if i'm handling this the
right way
like i'm handling this situation the
best way that i possibly can
because it's unfamiliar to me
i'm still like
shocked
and even though like maybe my heart
wasn't in it i felt safe and that my
safety i feel was put at risk i feel
like i was betrayed heavily and i'll be
okay i just
i'm just trying to figure it out
you know so i just need everyone to go
easy on me you're doing great
sorry no it's okay because there's no
there's no like right way to go about
this you're dealing with something that
is like so public and also hurtful to
you and there's a kid involved there's
no like rule book to how you should go
about it and sophia and i have been
saying this since the start
the way that we think you are handling
it is so
good and by the way as
you're doing it
so elegantly i know i would probably
burn down seven buildings at this point
yeah and you're doing such a good job
and i mean i have my i have my [ __ ]
petty moments and then i'm allowed to
you're a liar
you're completely allowed to you are
left like you're feeling so much on your
plate
you're such a good mommy to ocean yeah
really i mean like the fact that you
already like
you say that you like almost don't know
if you're doing it right but like the
fact that you even acknowledged that and
you're like but i'm going to keep doing
the best that i can there's so much much
clarity already yeah
i feel like you're at stages of of your
mental state where you should be at
maybe a year or two years you now and
it's like the fact that you're already
there
so soon after is is i mean your growth
is incredible what do you think has
helped you with the breakup then like
the most with like the transition like
who's have you talked to someone that
like your mom the most that's helped you
like for people that have got is going
through this like what do you think has
been the best
you guys are going to think i'm so weird
when i say speaking really
my mom has been amazing
but for me this is
something so much bigger that at
certain points in time
like i have to turn it over to a higher
power
and i
beg sometimes hourly for strength and
just like
release me from the bondage of self like
i go into my aaa prayers and i'm like
this is too much for me i'm in my head
i'm thinking 20 steps ahead i need i
need you to bring my head to where my
feet are right
and that's what is saving me like my
profound relationship with god in the
universe and i get so annoyed when
people talk about like their beliefs but
since you're asking like that
relationship is saving me right that's
amazing no because sometimes it's hard
when it's there's so much going on to
find something or anything to ground you
and go put me back to square one and i
know like i'm i'm the same way i
overthink things i think about like what
i need to do next in 10 years from now
and this and this like and i think of
every single person involved and it's
like that's not going to help me if i'm
overwhelmed right and i'm over my head
about this sometimes just talking to
someone
without having a response and just ears
because you could talk to your mom your
best friends your sisters about what
you're feeling but they're not living in
your experiences they're not having the
conversations that you've had they're
not feeling these things they're not the
mom to ocean there's so many things that
they don't ever they'll never understand
so just being able to sit and talk to
someone that understands
without a response is like i think you
nailed it i totally exactly what it is
it really is that i mean it's like so
weird to explain it but sometimes at
these like intense moments this is like
when you realize this is what i the most
which is just just talk about it without
actually hearing anyone's opinion right
and sometimes we do that with each other
it's like like even yesterday yesterday
i was telling her that she called me and
she said how are you and i started
screaming hysterically crying yeah
not good and she was like why and i'm
like just don't ask questions
and we got in a fight because she's like
i want to help you and i was like i
don't want help i just want to cry and
she's like okay
i get it i left her alone i asked her if
she had a tray for my food
she came out like so much like kitchen
appliances yeah sorry i'm not going to
give that up lala we love you so much
sorry i can't right i get it no don't no
by the way there's gonna be a day that i
don't cry one time we are talking about
it earlier this episode that i've had
this week
so it feels really good to let it out i
think we've cried three times this week
already we love it it's so good for you
yes yes so i think so i like crying and
i look cute after i'm all like redness
high so pretty
natural blush yeah like it's sweet like
people feel bad for me so i want to i
want to tell you that people feel bad
for me get out of here i want to tell
all the lists like very toxic about
really quick where they can find your
beauty products give them lala where can
they find it yes you can get give them
all a beauty at givethemlala.com
if you have little babies you can get
baby goods at give them lalababy.com
the second i found out i was pregnant i
was like
i will be pimping this baby out
and you're going on tour we're going on
tour you can get tickets um i give them
live.com a lot of people ask me like
what are you doing on tour i'm like
we're going to have the best time ever
yeah
yeah so you can find
tickets on give them live.com or um on
my instagram at la la kent we love you
okay who's the most genuine person ever
and one of my favorite episodes yeah
actually like
we say this but like actually because
you're so open and honest and i feel
like so many people are going to gain so
much insight about like how they can
even just take what you've gone through
and like using their own life
that alone is enough and so thank you
the tears are worth it
of course we love you we'll see you guys
next week bye
[Music]
you